oui au bout du conte mais bon bout de
deux mille ans oui mais non voilà après
beaucoup de souffrance après avoir été
conquis par un certain nombre d'entre
eux et ils se succèdent assez bon nous
on connaît attila gagne 10 peut-être
tamerlan peut-être un peu babur le
parlant tous ces siècles il ya une
succession de deux royaumes ou de mini
empire qui se succèdent en haute asie et
en asie centrale
qui effectuent des razzias plus ou moins
importantes sur les états seraient
sédentaires qui qui sont les états
riches puisque c'est dans les step
conserve la pauvreté il ya pas grand
chose donc leurs avantages comparatifs
ou utiliser un terme économique
moderne c'est vraiment l'heure
leur qualité militaire oui j'ai chaud le
plan guerriers ils sont d ailleurs assez
extraordinaire on va voir les principaux
intéressons nous à attila attila c'est
déjà un empire gigantesque quand il est
défait en 451 ou aux champs
catalauniques donc en france
voilà on voit là le seul empire dette il
est énorme oui c'est énorme c'est
éphémère comme beaucoup de ces empires
parce que bon ça que ça dure elles
connaissent et demi tout au plus il
s'effondre à sa mort et oui mais on
oublie que c'est un empire qui est très
grands nous on reste un peu concentré
sur ce qui s'est passé en occident et
tous ces empires sont généralement très
vaste alors attila et ckoi stature comme
mongols on va le voir on va voir son
visage hors période telle qu'on se le
représente
plus tard on va voir également ces
guerriers en tout cas le souvenir qu'on
en a conservé la réputation des tilal va
persévérer à travers les siècles alors
que vous l'avez dit c'est très éphémère
il arrive en france il est des faits il
va ensuite et essayer de conquérir rome
et puis se retire et mais pendant des
siècles on voit les départs les aînés un
oui on en parle dans les sagas
irlandaises ont la première guerre
mondiale et les anglais appellent les
allemands les uns d un don c'est alors
qu'il est bon finalement
d'abord il n'a pas vaincu
et était-il si barbare que l'idée que
l'on a conservé
oui et non bon c'était une autre culture
quand même tous les tous les
contemporains et qui décrivent les liens
les décrivent comme étant très différent
de tout ce qu'ils connaissent y compris
les cavaliers archers irano phone les
alains et les compagnies et donc ils
sont sont des cavaliers sont des archers
et ils sont d'une violence
extraordinaire c'était vraiment le cas
où il était violent parce que leurs
techniques de guerre c'est le raid ou la
razzia vous arrivez quelque part ou
massacrer tous vous prenez le but à vous
rentrez chez vous et après vous menacez
ces peuples de revenir et en général ils
vous donnent attributs pour pour qu'on
les laisse tranquilles et est il a
commenté t-il
il était comme on le décrit comme
beaucoup de ces chefs de guerre d'asie
centrale un petit trapu
très caractéristique mais on n'a pas
évidemment n'a pas de portrait de lui on
sait pas si et quelle langue parlée les
uns c'est pas si c'était une langue
turcophones si c'était du mongol on
pense bon les études récentes en
penserait plutôt que ce sont des il
était de langue mongole monf est on est
on est sûr de rien exactement où elle a
eu lieu non on pense que c'est à côté de
troyes mais bon on n'est pas sûr on ne
sait pas en fait on sait qu'il a été
jusqu'à orléans distancé parce qu'il ya
des témoignages ouais saint-aignan je
crois qu'il y avait écrit écrit
là-dessus donc on sait qu'il est passé à
orléans et qu' il a affronté à et sus le
général romain plus qui était allié avec
lego avec les wisigoths et qui les a
affronté quelque part vers la champagne
est alors quand on parle dans pires
qu'il s'agit d'un véritable empire il
est véritablement administrés cet empire
non c'est pas un vampire c'est un empire
de conquête 1 c'est un peu comme l'
empire de l'alexandre quoi je me dis
mais bon il arrive pile tout ils sont
les maîtres sur ce territoire le temps
qu'ils y sont mais après après leur
passage tu ouvres devient presque normal
bon les où blair ne repose pas comme le
dit l'adage
en fait elle repousse un allemand la ja
il ya toutes sortes de légendes qui
conseillait minutieux qui faisait cuire
leur steak soula sous sur le dos de leur
cheval alors c'est vrai je faisais
effectivement dans la viande sur le dos
de leur cheval
ce n'était pas leur unique source
d'alimentation ni même la principale
c'est surtout le lait qui leur leur
première source d'alimentation mais ça a
marqué beaucoup de
les
des contemporains tous les gens qui
décrivent depuis attila jusqu'à jusqu'à
la table en les décrivant train de le
faire cuire l'heureux leur bifteck
quelle influence at il eu at il a enfin
de cet empire très éphémère qui est qui
va jusque jusqu'au fin fond de l'europe
ça a marqué les contemporains ça on en
est sûr est-ce que ça a eu de
l'influencé est ce que c'est une
influence en ce sens que bon l'empiré
romain est en bout de course et c'est un
peu moins
le chant du cygne la bataille des champs
catalauniques où on ne gagne pas la
bataille m'enfin repousse attila on
s'est un peu le le dernier grand fait
d'armes d'un un soldat romain et après
l'empiré romain d'occident tous les cas
bon il s'effondre quoi alors ensuite
yahia gengis khan est ce qu on le
prononce gengis ou gainey comme on veut
moi je dois gaullisme enfin bon alors on
lui rend hommage 1
il ya des statuts énorme de de gengis
khan en mongolie et là on est au xiiie
siècle lui c'est un coq héros absolument
exceptionnel parce que le lempire de
gengis khan c'est gigantesque
elle sa j'adore vous avez vous
connaissez cette ce monument après je ne
suis pas allée
danser c'est fantastique parce c'est à
dire qu'il y en a eu pas mal de ces
conquérants des steppes et c'est lui le
plus grand parce que c'est lui d'abord
qui conquiert un vampire le plus vaste
oui on va le voir c'est fantastique en
très peu de temps oui ça va être les
seuls à l'est du pacifique à la mer
caspienne et ensuite s'est consolidée
par ses fils voilà enfin ses fils les
temps mais oui la chine la russie c'est
ça l'europe voilà c'est ça est bon il
passe beaucoup plus de temps et
met beaucoup plus d'énergie
asseoir son autorité sur les clans
mongols qui ne va pas c'est finalement
conquérir il reste du monde oui au fond
dit il part de rien jusqu'à absolument
de rien et il va y va il est dans une
tribu qui n'est pas d'une grande
importance et il va falloir unifier les
mongols ce qui est pas évident puisque
en raison des nomades fil à des
adversaires il a un ami qui l'aident à
un peu les échelons qui après les deux
les deux combattent pour le pouvoir
suprême et c'est lui qui remporte la
partie enfin il doit se s'est pas
uniquement par la force c'est pas dans
un coup d'état il doit se faire élire
c'est un peu comme une primaire d'une
présidence aujourd'hui il est vraiment
la réputation d'avoir été extrêmement
intelligent in this can bat wil pour
accomplir ce qu'il a accompli il faut
être très intelligent
bon il ne savait ni lire ni écrire
c'était un stratège de tout premier
ordre et il était bon dans tous les
domaines c'est à dire que aussi bien en
termes de renseignements de logistique
de préparation de stratégies
tactiques opération
les lois qui les dictent sont assez
progressistes pour l'époque notamment
faveur des femmes
oui alors les femmes mongols ont un rôle
très important
sa propre femme à lui porter un rôle un
rôle fondamental dans la construction de
cet empire puisque quand les hommes sont
à la guerre ce qui sont souvent ce sont
les femmes qui y gouverne en quelque
sorte et ce sont elles qui décident de
la succession
elle participe pour certaines d'entre
elles aux campagnes militaires beaucoup
suivre avec leur mari et leurs enfants
c'est le cas des nomades c'était déjà le
cas de shu et il a en fait vous arrivez
avec leurs femmes et leurs enfants
voient la
ccc c'est très différent des croisés
voilà c'est ça dont qu'elles ont une
part très active et tous les tous les
voyageurs occidentaux quand il arrive là
c'est une des premières choses qui
remarque c'est le rôle des femmes dans
cette société alors ses trois fils
ensuite vont prendre le relais et donc
la chine et chine devient devient une
colonie mongole et puis ensuite c'est
kubilaï qui voilà c'est ça alors il est
le premier son qui enfin avec kubilaï
arrivé à conquérir toute la chine parce
qu'en général ces cavaliers archers
d'asie centrale il se casse les dents
sur la chine c'est contre eux que avait
été dressé le mur 2 voilà les murs de
qingdao est tout à fait et alors eux
aussi sont des cavaliers archers on a
l'impression qu'il ya pas eu de de
progrès fondamentaux
au niveau militaire depuis attila non
bon il ya l'étrier à qu'elle n'avait pas
été là
mais sinon c'est là c'est la même
technique mais bon quand vous êtes
meilleur que toutes les armées du monde
n'a pas de raison de changer de
technique la seule le seul apport c'est
que il acquiert les techniques de sièges
des des peuples quiconque est nous dit
qu'ils importent la guerre
bactériologique qui catapulte des vaches
alors je sais pas si l'un vente mais il
utilise est bon il on utilise notamment
utilisé contre des génois en crimée le
port de crimée de cafard ce serait une
des causes de la la peste noire qui
puisqu'il catapulte des animaux mort de
la peste dans les cadavres même des
cadavres
il ya des relations d'époque d'ailleurs
décrivent comment tout cela s'est passé
alors eux ils vont arriver jusqu'en
pologne et hongrie 1
voilà donc qui viennent une première
fois en russie sous game is khan en 12
123 ils battent les russes à plate
couture ils reviennent en mongolie et le
général qui avait participé à cette
campagne saubot d'oeil
ça le démange de revenir en occident il
pense qu'il ya des choses à conquérir
qui a des richesses et avec le fils de
gags liste cannes au godet ils
organisent une grande campagne vers la
russie puis vers la russie vont était
bien la horde d'or voilà qui va y rester
pendant un temps mais ils seront arrêtés
en europe ils soient arrêtés alors ils
sont pas du tout arrêter enfin non non
ils vont ils écrasent les polonais et
les et hongrois et hongrois de deux
batailles qui se déroule en 48 heures
et
alors qu'ils allaient se projeter très
probablement vers l'ouest le camp mon
beurre rocco day et ils sont obligés de
revenir en mongolie vous devez lire le
nouveau voilà on a eu chaud car
maintenant il ya des théories qui disent
que finalement c'est peut-être pas parce
que le le camp est mort que la
météorologie était pas fort favorable je
sais pas moi je souscris plutôt à la
thèse du retour le troisième qu'on
connaît un peu moins que les deux
précédents parce qu'il va - opérer en
europe c'est à mes relances y mourir
timur le boiteux l'est au 14e siècle
[Musique]
lui là où il est il est assez fascinant
il a la réputation d'avoir été le
concurrent le plus sanguinaire de tous
les temps il est sa spécialité c'était
d'empiler les têtes voilà c'est simple
et de ses ennemis vous dites qu'il était
aussi l'un des meilleurs joueurs
d'échecs de son époque voilà c'est ce
qu'on dit
c'est pas un sauvage quoi c'était et
d'ailleurs il a dès l'instant où ils
savent où ils s'installent et quelque
part il convoquait les meilleurs
artistes les meilleurs ils les
envoyaient à samarcande extrêmement
raffiné voilà c'était très raffiné il a
eu de longues conversations avec
ibn-khaldoun qui est le père de la de la
philosophie politique voilà qu'il a
probablement à des deux trois plus
grands penseurs du moyen-âge il lui
avait proposé d'être son biographe
d'ailleurs oui il y en a eu d'autres qui
était moins favorable
je serai prêt ciblera l'h2o n'aurait
voulu être son biographe mais ils en
parlent il décrit ses ouïes la versa
s'est il arrêté il efface eux c'est
extraordinaire pour un pour un type qui
fait de la philosophie politique voilà
avec sa phase du plus gros conquérante
sur des blocs fallait deux il ya une
fascination mutuelle pathway tamerlan
est fasciné par et pour ça je me suis
bien de la prise de damas je crois au
moment où les têtes s'empilent quoi
voilà c'est ça donc bon il ne radu et
évidemment on lui dit est ce que vous
pourriez pas renié les gens n'ont pas
renié rien du tout pendant pile les
têtes on en fait des pyramides et puis
voilà donc c'est de la propagande
intelligente
c'est terrorise tout laisser ça donc
l'idée c'est que si une ville ne se rend
pas en vente à l'intérieur et hop
pyramide de crâne et sa tribu c'est
ainsi qu'est la récession qu'à s'est
alors lui il a il est vraiment aux
abords de l'europe
tamerlan il rentre pas en europe alors
il
bon il bat les ottomans en 14 ans de à
ankara il bat bat yasi était lui même un
très grand guerrier puisqu'il avait
écrasé une formidable armée occidentale
qui étaient étaient venus à sa rencontre
il les avait battus quelques années plus
tôt en bulgarie à nicopolis est en berne
en arrive avec ses armées et bon ben il
fait qu'une bouchée bayazid il envoie
quelques armes et un peu vers l'ouest où
ils combattent les chevaliers de rhodes
les hospitaliers qui sont soit à rhodes
bon c'est pareil les écrase et et
l'occident n'intéresse pas beaucoup ou
qui revient il revient la chaîne non
plus il s'y était alors la chine si la
chine m'intéresse c'est même son grant
c'est le grand objectif de sa vie et en
14 ans 5 il a 75 ans probablement il
part en campagne contre la chine et
quelques semaines plus tard il y meurt
d'une pneumonie ben fini on arrête ne
vont pas conquérir la chine et son
empire se désagrège quasiment à sa mort
un mythe alors ils durent un peu mais
ses descendants sont beaucoup plus
intéressés par les sciences et les arts
d'ailleurs il a un petit fils qui
devient un astronome de très grande
renommée
ils construisent de très belles villes
donc à samarcande à erat et après les
ouzbeks qui sont des descendants de
mongols
leur foncent dessus les écraser bompas
et c'est terminé pour les timouride sauf
que un de ses descendants dabur
veut absolument reconquérir lempire de
tamerlan se casse les dents mais en
revanche il va en inde où là ils font un
autre empire qu'il va durer celui des
grands moghols way est effectivement les
grands moghols qui règne euros sur
l'inde jusqu'à ce que les anglais voilà
art ils peuvent voilà et alors tous ces
royaumes ces empires qui se succèdent le
dernier dont vous parlez donc qui va
s'éteindre xviiie siècle sous le règne
de catherine ii c'est le canada de
crimée où le voilà lui aussi quand même
très important l époque qu'un
alors lui c'est le dernier il fallait
des petits résidus minuscule un peu
partout des petits chefs de guerre
mongol toi qui en a eu 1 jusqu'au xxème
siècle l'abbé le oui dans les albums
chez vic qu'on finit par exemple le
dernier véritable cana c'est celui de
crime et qui est longtemps alliées aux
ottomans et quand les ottomans sont
battues par les russes qui ont reconquis
en gros lot petit à petit tout le
territoire occupé précédemment par les
mongols avec la chute des turquie non
plus d'alliés bon ben là ça se termine
un peu lamentablement faut bien dire en
face à la durée du siècle quand même
hein ça ouais ouais si l'on part
d'attila jusqu'au xviiie siècle ouais
c'est le grand foyer perturbateurs et
les niveaux en fait ils sont d'une
certaine manière responsables des
croisades par exemple ce qui pousse les
voilà on est con côté pour en créer les
croit alors que c'est d'autre si on
revient aux croisades en 1071 vous avez
un
chef de guerre
celle où on turc qui bat les byzantins
et les byzantins fonds appelle donc aux
occidentaux ou venir les débarrasser de
cette menace pour les aider à la
contenir et c'est là que va commencer
l'idée d'envoyer des croisés au fond les
perturbations dont ils sont responsables
ont des conséquences parfois très
lointaine oui tout à fait ma sur la
chine dont l'histoire de chine est
bercée par parcelle de ses cavaliers des
steppes celle de l'inde aussi dans une
certaine mesure la perse
et puis même les autres empires les
ottomans et les empires qui étaient là
avant et les seldjoukides essais ils
sont
les mamelouks combattent contre les
mongols leur grand ennemi leur grand
adversaire c'est pas les croisés c'est
les mongols qu'est ce qui vous a amené
un oblin vous intéresser à tous et nos
bas vous aviez fait des gènes biographie
tamerlan bas ça ça m'intéresse depuis
toujours j'ai écrit des articles sur ce
livre sur tamerlan
est bon ce qui m'intéresse ce sont les
grands bouleversements géopolitiques
dans l'histoire est bon tout les les
grands mécanismes qui opèrent
ces jeux
entre et à ce qu'on appelle les
relations internationales sont pas
toujours de très bonnes relations
d'ailleurs et dans toute cette histoire
ben franchement je pense que c'est
l'histoire des cavaliers turco mongols
c'est celle qu'il ya le plus de
conséquences sur ses relations et ça va
à rebours de ce qu'on imagine parce
qu'au fond on en a gardé un souvenir
théorisé en europe on a l'impression que
ça n'a eu aucune conséquence au fond ils
soudent hariri puis sont repartis voilà
c'est alors qu'en fait ils ont
bouleversé le monde voilà ils ont
bouleversé le monde y compris le nôtre
puisque ça s'est répercuté mais
indirectement la plupart du temps
sur l'occident mais les autres peuples
elle est parlée au géorgien et compagnie
ou hongrois d'ailleurs est bon
mais voilà ils s'en souviennent mais il
faut que les personnalités notamment
alors peut-être parce qu'on les connaît
mieux gengis khan est à mes relances ont
absolument fascinante
attila j'ai l'impression qu'on en sait
moins oui on sait pas grand chose de lui
donc c'est beaucoup plus dit tu à
l'époque bon la perception de ces
gens-là change à l'épaule d'attila c'est
vraiment des fois on les décrit comme à
moitié homme à moitié bête
donc ce sont ses pires que des barbares
et après ça a évolué les mongols on a
longtemps espéré que ce serait nos
grands alliés contre les musulmans donc
là ils deviennent beaucoup plus gentille
et le portrait qu'on fait d'eux beaucoup
plus positif et il faut se souvenir que
marco polo quand il décrit la cour de
chine en fait c'est lé bon goal voilà
donc ces combis là c'est que saad hariri
le fils de vis des giallorossi bilal n'a
rien à voir avec la description que
qu'on faisait auparavant
d'attila ou même de gagny ce cas c'est
un personnage absolument ultra puissant
est super rapide et voilà c'est ça et on
pensait qu'il ya une légende comme quoi
les mongols serait serait converti au
christianisme
donc on a longtemps cru c'est à l'époque
des croisades
bas longtemps cru que ce serait des
alliés naturels contre les musulmans et
la légende du royaume du prêtre jean
voilà tout à fait ça les croisés parce
qu'il y avait un royaume canal qu il ya
une lettre apocryphe qui a été écrite
sur ce royaume le prêtre jean devait
venir et sauver la chrétienté de l'islam
les conquérants de la steppe d'attila au
canad crime et du cinquième au xviiie
siècle c'est le nouveau livre d'arnaud
blain qui vient de paraître aux éditions
ces composés ont fait une pause merci
arnaud blin ont fait une pause et on se
retrouve juste après avec arthur jugnot
[Musique]
la fed pourrait bien fermer le robinet
la majorité de ses membres se disent
favorables au top twin une réduction des
achats d'actifs aujourd'hui on est dans
quelque chose qui ne peut pas être
modifiée vous êtes obligés d'en remettre
à chaque fois un petit peu plus
l'économie réelle elle suit pas donc
c'est le moment de communiquer au saut
modo de faire comprendre à tout le monde
dont cette politique elle pose des
problèmes on est en train de mettre
l'économie réelle à risque on la soumet
vraiment un risque important les banques
centrales aujourd'hui son market
dépendantes et uniquement marqué de
l'épaule donc si elles ne veulent pas
aujourd'hui réduire leurs achats c'est
tout simplement parce que elles savent
très bien que le jour où elle annonce
seront réellement une réduction de leurs
achats les marchés vont s'effondrer
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions ou du
symbolisme en terme de timing ce sera
absolument parfait et ils veulent une
fanfare par vaut aussi pour la coupe du
monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le fou ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent si c'est que
dalle en fait c'est peanuts donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons d'ailleurs plutôt mélioratif
plus totale
il
[Musique]
arthur jugnot vous êtes comédien metteur
en scène producteur directeur de théâtre
et vous avez co écrit avec flavie péan
saint-exupéry le mystère de l'aviateur
une pièce que vous mettez en scène au
splendid avec davy sardou et flavie péan
dans les rôles principaux
voici l'image que vous avez choisi pour
notre époque
c'est le la fameuse gourmette la fameuse
grand maître oui j'en parle je suppose
bah oui
là je peux lire antoine de saint-exupéry
c'est la gourmette de saint-exupéry
qu'on a fini par retrouver ouais en fait
c'est grave grâce à cette anecdote
on a eu envie d'écrire la pièce avec
flavie en fait pour résumer très
rapidement il disparaît en mer en le 31
juillet 44 l'an 50 ans mystère et
énormément de théories énormément
aujourd'hui parce que ailleurs qu' à
l'époque océni peut-être qu'ils y parti
pour rejoindre une de ses maîtresses est
ce que il s'est suicidé parce qu'il
avait le blues est ce que il s'est fait
tirer dessus il ya même l'hypothèse
s'était abîmé en mer il a été repêché et
torturé par les allemands file plein
plein plein air c'est une telle vedette
saint-exupéry puisque le petit prince
c'est le livre le plus lu le plus
traduit après la bible que on peut pas
penser qu'il est mort normalement en
guerre comme n'importe quel pilote de
char on ne peut pas le penser et puis on
savait pas en plus ou weight il était
parti et puis c'est quand même une
époque où il y avait moins de nos logis
et enfin bon bref monkey disparu en mer
pendant 50 on sait pas ce qui se passe
et moi et en 98 il ya un pêcheur
qui au large de marseille dans son filet
de pêche retrouve cette gourmette oui je
me souviens hockey et moi j'étais passé
à côté de cette année parce que je m'en
souviens encore bien revenez pas qu'on
puisse remonter la gourmette de
saint-exupéry on était 80 18 juste après
la coupe du monde je pense que j'étais
encore en train de de décuver pas bon et
voilà ma chez gt gt jeunes adultes donc
cette anecdote m'étais un peu voilà
l'été un peu passé comme ça et puis
jeudi la carotte qui me raconte cette
anecdote est donc ce pêcheur trouve
cette gourmette grâce à cette gourmette
ils vont retrouver l'avion
de saint-exupéry
grâce à cet avion dont ils ont la
position grâce à ça ils vont avec les
hommes également et les bons le les bons
rapports qu'on aime avec nos voisins il
retrouve la personne qui était là et qui
avait ni bages et j'ai tiré sur un avion
ils vont voir cet homme est un vieux
monsieur en disant voilà vous avez
apparemment abattu
saint-exupéry et là c'est tellement
s'effondre à temps mais c'est pas
possible le petit prince mon livre de
chevet saint-exupéry est un héros il
fait une conférence de presse il dit si
j'avais su je n'aurais pas tiré et je
trouve ça tellement et le hasard de
retrouver cette gourmette dans un filet
de pêche enfin moi on est vraiment je
trouve ce voile à se plaindre des portes
tellement extraordinaire qu avec flavie
on s'est dit bon bah faut qu'on écrive
une histoire autour de ça on va on va
parler de évidemment de saint-exupéry on
va raconter une histoire aussi dans le
présent qui va s'entrelacer pour parler
justement de 2 qu'est ce que peut
apporter
saint-exupéry et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que notre aide pas vraiment
l'auteur on traite vraiment l'homme
l'aviateur l'aventurier et de se dire
voilà qu est ce qu'aujourd'hui cet homme
peut nous apporter en plus de son oeuvre
on va regarder le teaser
il est tout le temps dans la provoc avec
moi maintenant c'est parce que ma fille
était nazi qui est personnes à long
terme il était pas maxime il a porté sa
croix et bien les parties champ on l'a
enterrée il ya deux heures tu peux pas
être un peu cool pour une fois il ya des
dessins du divin spartoo yacht est
fasciné par antoine de saint-exupéry
difficulté intéressés à lui mx 5 minutes
du 200 m
il a eu une vie incroyable playdead
aventure autant donc
moss aux commandes de son groupe a
réussi à faire un deuxième temps
et se pose comme une
bouffée chevalier de la légion d'honneur
au titre de l'aéronautique antoine a
ouvert deux nouvelles lignes d'un bien
sûr
[Musique]
pourtant de se dire très ingrate pour
commencer à changer sur saint-exupéry ce
qu'un premier pas
quand j'ai appris qu'il était comme moi
un bon jour je vous en rendrez faire un
baptême de l'air
[Musique]
simplement volé
comme disait mon bon ami jean mermoz
paix à son âme l'accident pour nous ce
serait de mourir dans un
tout ça il pourra plus jamais piloté
c'est très fidèle
c'est mal me connaître mademoiselle
alors en fait arthur jugnot vous
l'auriez écrit pour le cinéma on vous
aurait dit c'est beaucoup trop cher
robin je l'aurais pas écrit libé masse
en revanche seul four au théâtre on peut
faire du cinéma au théâtre d'une
certaine manière et c'est beaucoup plus
facile ouais serre que c'est comme les
romans c'est encore plus simple si on
veut écrire un éléphant qui volent et
qui écrase un building bon ça ne
s'apprend quelques lignes nous c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué il faut quand
même créé une scénographie mais c'est
vrai que on n'a pas de limites avec un
peu de vidéo avec des astuces des décors
qui s'ouvre etc on peut on peut se
permettre d peut faire le biopic d'un
aviateur
navigateur c'est vrai que ça peut-être
plus compliqué aussi sauf que j' étais
assis dans votre place mélodies bourg et
que vous connaissez bien puisque lll a
fait la course des géants au bélier
paris via internet que vous dirigez et
je disais que pour moi il y avait une
vraie tendance depuis quelques années
incarnez un peu symboliquement par
alexis michalik qui on a l'impression
que les gens de qui font du théâtre en
france veulent faire la course avec le
cinéma plus faire la course avec le
cinéma qu'avec shakespeare au fond
balasko alors la course avec le site n'a
en tous cas on je pense qu'on est aussi
une génération qui a été élevé avec le
cinéma et avec notamment les séries les
séries feuilletonnantes où tout d'un
coup on veut savoir ce qui va se passer
où ça va très vite et on revient en
arrière beaucoup à travers le mas et les
flashbacks et settat et c'est vrai que
d'avoir été élevé là dedans comme
spectateur je pense que ça nous ça crée
des auteurs qui donc sont dansées rythme
là aussi mais c'est vrai que
1h25 on traverse 70 ans aurait que trois
conflits ya la guerre il ya plein de
choses et puis une tendance aussi qui
est également dans la littérature c'est
qu'on a tendance à vouloir raconter la
vie des hommes illustres et
nombre de romanciers français de
romancière d'ailleurs se met à la place
de telle ou telle personnalité et on
retrouve ça dans le théâtre c'était
rostand réduisent l'accès saint-exupéry
il ya une tentation vous avez envie de
parler du réel vous avez plus tellement
envie de faire des pièces
d'imagination ben on en fait aussi je
pense qu'on mélange après je pensais
ddc des rencontres avec des avec des
personnalités des personnages qui sont
tellement ces personnages sont tellement
inspirant voilà qu'on crée en général on
crée des histoires autour de deux de ses
illustres auteurs ou souvent des auteurs
des jets fait les auteurs sont fascinés
par les auteurs on a un truc de mise en
abyme comme ça et et saint-exupéry
pourquoi lui alors vous nous avez dit à
toute l'histoire de la redécouverte ou
du moins de l'éclaircissement du mystère
puisque hausse est non seulement où il
est tombé alors moi j'ai jamais vu
d'image dans l'avion est ce qu est le
squelette de saint-exupéry il y a le il
ya le
l'épave qui peut être encore visitées on
peut y aller le scot n'est plus là mais
il ya les parents l'épave ou et est donc
maintenant ces mêmes qui l'a abattu et
est lui aussi le sait ou en tout cas là
dessus il a appris le pauvre et et
juste plus que je voulais des meilleurs
mais oui vous aviez un rapport avec
saint-exupéry c'est le petit prince
alors moi j'avais un rapport je pense
comme la majorité français du petit
prince de cette fable on se dit ah tiens
ce joli c'est comme a peur vous disiez
tout à l'heure que c'est le moment le
plus vendu après la bible enfin l'oeuvre
est un peu comme la bible c'est un peu
une
pour moi je fais de fixer des gens non
mais c'est que
une speed de une espèce de guide de
conduite un peu pour moi la mine un peu
ce côté là dire voilà il faut essayer de
faire le bien il faut essayer de faire
ça et je trouve que le petit prince est
un peu ça c'est à dire attention il faut
garder son âme d'enfant attention
l'argent réglo pas tous failli là à sa
manière voilà il ya ces codes de
conduite et je trouve que pour après
avoir étudié la vie de certaines rues
péri parce que sa vie passionnante on
parle là on a parlé de sa mort au début
mais sa vie est dingue oui surtout
qu'après avoir passé son brevet de
pilote quand ils sont six militaires à
la fin des années 20 il a beaucoup de
mal à trouver du travail parce qu'il a
raté tous ses examens et il est
représentant placier ils vont bientôt et
merci à l'essai dans des camions à 12
ans et prendre l'argent sans prévenir sa
mère et il va se faire ils payent un
pilote pour faire un baptême de l'air
à 12 ans il s'est scratché mais 25 fois
il a fini avec un brave le chemin qu'il
était pilote avec alors je sais pas je
serai peut-être déjà d'avoir fait
qu'après on a dit qu'il n'était pas très
bon pilote ouais peut-être les preuves
sur paille cercle et les pilotes étaient
jalouses
de l'écrivain était jaloux du pilote on
se souvient mais du petit prince il a
écrit deux grands livres de records
mais mais c'est vrai que on est quand
même sur un homme sont des fardiers
quinze mille anecdotes mais c'est
passionnant sont quand il s'est marié
conçu après quoi ils ont annulé le
mariage parce qu'il pleurait tellement
qu'elle a dit je ne veux pas m'arrêter
un petit plat ils ont annulé ils ont
recalé décalé le mariage il y en a une
autre formidable qu'un lui offre un bébé
lion ils sont à d'acteurs et le lion
commença à paniquer dans l'avion parce
qu'il est évidemment jamais autant
d'avions et donc c'est un texte pour le
l'oeil ou pas jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
sommet puisse terminer le voyage son
mécanicien andré prévost famille à ya
tellement d on est obligé de tuer sinon
ça faisait un wikipedia l'anecdote donc
il fallait quand même raconté par mais
sa vie est le lion vous aurez accès peur
sur le sur la scène du théâtre
évidemment meslier voulait
le lourd présent évidemment mais une
fois qu'on connaît sa vie puisque
justement dû étudier ça vivre en
profondeur l'oeuvre du petit prince
prend une ampleur extraordinaire et
parce qu'on se rend compte de tout ce
qui est de lui de tout ce qu'ils sont
vécus enfin là et c c'est absolument
passionnant enfin moi je suis
passionné par par l'homme
laventure favola et et l'idée c'est de
dire comme aujourd'hui un monde qui
serait sur son portable tout l'argent et
le dire je vais te raconter l'histoire
l'histoire minella jones et tu as
décroché un peu de ton téléphone ébats
avec saint-exupéry n'a même pas besoin
de prendre une fiction peut prendre
l'histoire sein du lycée saint-exupéry
et passionné toute une génération grâce
à ça c'est donc au théâtre du splendid
un tel que vous dirigez pas pas tout à
fait
et c'est alors soit 21h soit 16h30 c'est
ça va tenir samedi le samedi à 16h30 et
21h et bien bonne chance pour la suite
eva merci free
[Musique]
parce qu'elle le thorel vous êtes la
commissaire de l'exposition libre
figuration années 80 au musée de calais
on va voir dans un instant beaucoup de
peintures françaises américaines
allemandes ou russes de cette époque les
années 80 c'était vraiment le retour de
la peinture après que l'on nous est
expliqué doctement que la peinture était
morte et que l'avenir c'était l'art
conceptuel
mais d'abord l'image que vous avez
choisi pour notre époque la voici
à de la pâte
c'est un montage en fait qu a fait une
de mes amies à marie-laure batani qui
dirige le fonds leclerc pour la culture
et avec qui j'ai travaillé sur ce projet
d'exposition au moment du premier
confinement où on était complètement
désespéré l'une et l'autre hyper active
et les l'une concerne bretagne et
l'autre à paris est en fait allé partie
de une sculpture hyperréaliste de
johnson justement un figuratif américain
et elle s'est elle même grille mais avec
des rouleaux une vieille taupe est un
tout petit chariot et j'ai trouvé que
c'était une espèce de dérision à la joue
plutôt marck c est là où d allen est de
garder le sens de l'humour ce qui est la
chose qu'on s'est tous un peu essayé à
faire dans cette ville c'est vrai que
l'ennemi rempli c'est pas seulement le
coc vie d'un cessé depuis le début du
21e siècle on est dans une époque
d'abondance oui mais alors on se met
plus vraiment les rouleaux sur la tête
ni elle ni moi pas tout à fait deux
séjours l'un et il ya beaucoup d'hommes
qui poussent des caddies aussi moisie et
puissent avait un petit côté punk elle
est bien avec l'expo aussi donc ça va
amuser j'aurais pu montrer à saute pas
lourde puisque moi pendant ce temps là
elle faisait des courses hamas et des
palourdes au bord de la mer alors
revenons aux années 80 et l'exposition
libre figuration musée de calais qu'est
ce qui se passe à sont là sur la scène
artistique en europe et aux états unis à
ce moment là il ya déjà l'art qui sort
dans la rue rappelle le graffiti et
recel c'est le nom la figuration libre
c'est le nom en france où médias peindre
un peu plus tard et puis les allemandes
ans appelé les nouveaux sauvages et les
artistes américains on va parler du
graffiti pour keith haring pour au
basket s'est appuyé pour tous ceux qui
les qui les accompagnent ces moments où
c'est un peu le strict ce qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui le street art
mais le graffiti c'est aussi sur d c'est
aussi sur un support et un support de
peinture est donc là on voit là la salle
avec les artistes américains ou l'aller
les ripoux l'un est en fait l'idée
c'était de sortir de l'art du cheval est
d'aller véritablement dans la rue mais
pas en mode impressionniste en mode
sampling en mode liberté d'aller dans le
métro comme le faisait keith haring et
de et de s'exprimer un peu sur tous les
supports y compris sur les murs du métro
sur les murs dans la rue il est libre en
fête c'est le mot libre qui est très
important c'était c'était la période
punk et c'était l'idée de faire un peu
des choses pas très autorisée ce qu'ils
ont à peu près tous en commun que la
plupart d'entre eux en tout cas en tout
cas les meilleurs il sort pas d'école de
peu ils sortent pas des beaux-arts ils
s'entraident écoles non mais je
travaille à l'époque c'était considéré
comme un peu ringard et même d'ailleurs
un artiste comme roberto qu'abbott king
le brésilien de cette exposition il
s'est fait virer des beaux-arts alors
c'était plus aux arts déco c'est dans
les écoles en province ça c'est pour la
france à new york oui keith haring et
basques à fond quand même un peu des
études d'arts mais sinon pour la plupart
en tout cas par exemple en russie c'est
pas du tout des artistes officiels ils
sont à saint pétersbourg et ce sont des
artistes qui se forment eux mêmes mais
qui ont tout de même une culture
artistique on est on est pas dans juste
la signature on n'est pas dans justement
d'un street art on est tout même dans
des artistes qui ont une culture de
l'histoire que ce soit basquiat aux
états unis où boiron offrant si vous
visiter l'histoire de l'art l'autre est
bien et puis de quoi il parle mais
c'est vrai que il arrive alors justement
commençant par la france la figuration
libre voilà des premiers tableaux de
françois boisrond
le suivant c'est la grotte alors j'aime
particulièrement parce qu'il est à boire
danser parce qu'il assimile à un
formidable aussi mais c'est ce qu'on
appelle sa part le il ya de logo voilà
la grogne je vais je les adore ça c'est
un vrai bpt il est donc un peu je suis
content de revoir il va revenir qu'à
voir ce qu'on fait le dire à voir
également combas puisque la figuration
libre en france et boiron combas di rosa
blanchard et quelques autres là c'est un
des premiers tableaux de et catherine
viallet et voilà là c'est un des
premiers tableaux de combas on va en
voir d'autres avec là on reconnaît
davantage le style de combat avec
l'attentât devant lambert
son succès va être très rapide c'est le
plus doué c'est le plus celui qui marche
tout de suite
piketty c'est ça c'est ça justement di
rosa ensuite qu'ils étaient à votre
place il ya pas très longtemps hervé y
avait dans cette émission et ce qui se
passe en france comment il soit
accueillie
finalement ils sont ils sont bien
accueillis c'est ça qui est assez
curieux qui avaient bazooka avant avec
explications etc qui avaient commencé à
remettre la peinture en route et tout
d'un coup ils prennent le devant de la
scène et ils ont vraiment la lumière
seulement ils sont très jeunes vingt et
quelques années tout jeune ils sont
absolument que jeunes mais ils vont être
exposées tout de suite et
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est par exemple
un artiste comme robert combas il est
tout de suite acheté par un des plus
gros marchands du monde d'aujourd'hui
qui est maintenant équipé d'une dalle
bischofberger pardon et est donc y
rendre dans des très très très grosse
collection très vite les musées les aime
moins les musées reste art contemporain
d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui il ya
assez peu de alors ça c'est la raison de
cette exposition qu'on a vraiment
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup travaillé on
peut voir de temps en temps tout de même
combat boiron et di rosa mais le
mouvement des libres sigur à sion il a
jamais là d'ailleurs cette exposition
elle ait eu à landerneau la lieu à
calais mais elle n'est pas encore à
paris
vraiment pas de peinture c'est pas beau
c'est vulgaire la lie à la seule offre
de deux basques alors il faut dire que
basquiat non plus pas été achetées par
les musées ni en france ni aux états
unis je crois qu'on a qu'un tableau de
base 2 dans les musées français au cnam
oui voilà où se définit en a quasiment
aucun et la célèbre valse cas que vous
avez dans cette expo mais elle est très
drôle ce sont tous à bout ouais alors
j'en avais plus dans la précédente
version mais là du fait de la fermeture
du monde j'ai pas pu faire de transports
internationaux et les faire venir des
états unis comme la dernière fois donc
ses sabots de bastia c'est une histoire
très drôle en fait
basque et à rentrer chez yvon lambert en
87 donc il a enfin une exposition en
france et puis pour yvon lambert fait
son travail de marchands et donc il veut
lui présenter un collectionneur ils ont
un rendez-vous et baskets disparu il est
parti manger
des gâteaux un peu spéciaux fumée
amsterdam et en un petit peu de produits
il n'est pas là au rendez vous et en
rentrant pour se faire pardonner il
offre cette perte de sabou qui lâchés
sur un marché et qui raconte toute une
histoire autour de moby dick et la
liberté il les offre à yvon lambert qui
les a toujours gardé et qui a bien voulu
nous les nous les prêter pour cette expo
basquiat est mort jeune ainsi que son
alter ego à l'époque keith haring qui
lui meurt du sida ce qui fait que les
prix s'envolent d'ailleurs il est
homosexuel on sait qu'il est le sida et
on pense qu'il va mourir et donc les
prix de keith haring vont s'envoler
je veux dire très célèbre très très bas
là on voit deux deux oeuvres d'air qui
ont été très très très rarement
présentées en france parce que de la
même manière que j'ai renouvelé j'ai
cherché des oeuvres vous pouvez trouver
ici et c'est un collectionneur qui très
très gros collectionneurs de street et
de graffitis qui nous les a traités qui
a accepté qu'on les sorte ils sont un
bon cd c'est une revisitation l'histoire
de l'art extrêmement sexué avec la
joconde
qui ressemble à un sexe masculin et
d'autres d'autres ils ont exposé
ensemble boiron combas di rosa keith
haring et basques end aux états unis un
pas en france si si si alors qu'ils
savent non papa avec basque armée a
phase i avec basquiat au musée d'art
moderne de la ville de paris en 84 sa
seule exposition s'appelle france usa
après ils partent aux états unis et il
explose chez tony chaffre asie dans
l'autre sens je sais plus et en revanche
hervé perdriel va organiser un événement
24 heures du mans et là ça va être
keith haring et françois boisrond qui
vont faire des grands desseins et alors
à cette occasion d'ailleurs vous il ya
le capot de la voiture un week end la
femme de war on à l'époque
qu'ils ont accepté de me prêter c'est la
première fois qu'on monte cette pièce le
capot de voiture et ce par keith haring
et c'est vraiment il n'avait jamais été
montrés dans la sortie du garage l'année
dernière pour le doit plus beau
alors tout ça au même moment ça se passe
également en allemagne on va voir des
tableaux et en russie et on voit bien un
peu partout hein c'est la figuration
c'est le retour de la figuration c'est
important après de longues années
d'abstraction mais on voit bien aussi l'
influence du rock du punk
de la bande dessinée des dessins animés
des jeux vidéo de la pub tout ça au même
moment tout ça est en train de rentrer
dans la peinture au fond a totalement
c'est très très importante mais en étant
reproduit un peu bêtement je veux dire
comme le faisait andy warhol n'ont
en tout cas pas à l'identique s'est
transformé puis ça ça rentre
effectivement dans une histoire quand
nina childress d'airé poulain montre
pollux elle rajoute à côté de l'arbre à
couleurs de herbin d'un artiste moderne
qui donne une signification couleur et
elle retravaille elle retravaille les
tableaux et les russes c'est pareil là
on a on a un tableau de crise à naves
d'un russe on voit très bien le lien
avec les constructivistes avec tous les
artistes de l'histoire de la modernité
en russie alors après ecdc des vrais
vrai punk qui sont complètement dans la
clandestinité puisque à l'époque on est
avant la pérestroïka d'ailleurs ils ont
pas rencontrer les autres artistes bon
on voit ces c'est tout à fait identique
y retrouve le noir le punk il ya
absolument tout mais ces tableaux là on
les voit prend en france en europe dans
le monde en dehors de saint pétersbourg
pour la première fois n'hésitez jamais
sorti et c'est une histoire formidable
c'est qu'en fait trois femmes une
journaliste de l afp et deux autres qui
travaillait à l'ambassade à moscou vont
rencontrer africa un des artistes russes
qui d'ailleurs représente la russie à la
biennale de venise en 2002 qu'ils aient
les rencontres africa les emmène à saint
pétersbourg et se créer une histoire et
elles vont leur acheter des tableaux
qu'elles vont ramener en france et que
je vais alors il y en a une autre elle
les avait déjà montré une partie de sa
collection et les deux autres accepté là
pour la première fois de nos départs
étaient annoncés je trouve cette
exposition d'autant plus intéressant
qu'il ya une vraie nostalgie pour les
années 80 à la fois de la part de ceux
qui les ont vécus et qui regrettent
l'époque de leurs 20 ans mais aussi des
enfants des de la jeune génération qui
pensent qu'on était très libre très
riche qui avait du travail partout c'est
totalement faux bond enfin libre on
était certainement peut-être un peu plus
nice vont elles étaient peut-être
puisque aujourd'hui 16 heures mais je
veux dire par là que la dimension
plastique et surtout la peinture de
l'est cette époque a joué un très grand
rôle dans l'esthétique des années 80 et
cette esthétique aujourd'hui que tout le
monde connaît mais on ne connaît pas
forcément les peintures qui l'auront qui
lui ont donné naissance ou du moins qui
ont participé à son éclosion à tout à
fait ben là on a un exemple
s'est apprécié de voir
la couverture d'actual avec nina hagen
on a des artistes un conte le disait
qu'ils font un conte un concert on voit
la petite photo nina hagen avec le cente
celi et salomé donc il joue dans des
concerts et on voit le rapport avec ce
ballet sur l'après midi d'un faune donc
avec le corps pas et la manière dont
nous chano castelli va repeindre après
leur performance les corps comme dans
l'est dans les débats l'aide de
stravinsky donc on est vraiment encore
une fois nous un rapport à l'histoire de
l'arc est tout à fait étonnant et qu'on
comprend pas toujours suffisamment
compte sur le sur la force de ses
tableaux en tant que le tableau est
alors celui là il est c'est un tableau
de de hervé di rosa qu'on a retrouvés à
londres cet été
être patrick blanc cherche à acheter
s'appelle la rue du malheur alors
j'avais déjà la tacc de la rue du
malheur et donc ça c'est le sait le
premier tableau de la série et c'est
vraiment cela on sait montmartre on va
peut-être pas très très bien mais c'est
une rue avec des prostituées et puis
tous les petits personnages qui sont
sortis des bd et qui réinvente et qu'ils
se réapproprient auquel il donne vie et
que son frère va transformer en
sculpture et donc on a on a tout ça
aussi dans l'exposition et puis aussi
avec des objets de l'époque parce qu'à
calais ya deux musées et à musée des
beaux-arts et à la cité de la mode et de
la dentelle est comme ma première
version des disques ou rentrez pas dans
un musée je fais huguelet pu avoir la
déployer sur les deux et pour créer un
lien avec la mode on a demandé à tous
ces artistes de chercher dans leurs
greniers et nous ont retrouvé ce qui
portait à l'époque c'est un des blues
ont peint des caisses de moto ddd ranger
ce pas enfin un vrai c'était partout
elle tient l estrac jusqu'à quand elle
et jusqu'au 2 janvier ce qu'on fait on
fait dire et à l'exposition longtemps
donc à la fois au musée des beaux-arts
et la cité de la dentelle et de la mode
les deux à calais merci parce qu'elle le
thorel et ben merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la veille d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte l on soit vient de
l'ignorance aujourd'hui on a une gauche
extrême
[Musique]